[Music]
anyone who's played breath of the wild
has likely stumbled upon the master
sword at some point
i would hope so anyway and if you had
the hearts to do it it was yours for the
taking
but as some of you know for link this is
actually the second time in his life
that he acquired the sword
he already used it during the calamity
100 years ago
but because he fell in battle the sword
was taken away from him and he had
acquired a second time the first time he
pulled the sword is
something we never get to see in the
game and takes place even before any of
the memory cut scenes from before
or during the calamity but monster maze
i hear you think
didn't we already see how link first got
the master sword you know in that little
game called
hyrule warriors age of calamity and well
yes yes we did but as i and other
theorists have pointed out since the
game's release
there are some issues with this part of
age of calamity now don't get me wrong i
greatly enjoyed the game i loved the
epic setting i enjoyed the combat
and suga is life but when you study the
story beats of the game a bit closer you
quickly find out that there are some
aspects conflicting with that witch
breath of the wild and its complimentary
book creating a champion set up
most of these inconsistencies are
nitpicks at best and can easily be
chalked up to simple mistakes and
oversights but the way link acquires the
master sword stands out and cannot be
dismissed in the same way
so in this video i want to do two things
first i want to explain why the way link
gets the master sword in age of calamity
cannot possibly have occurred in a
similar manner in breath of the wild
secondly i want to give my take on how i
think link got the master sword in
breath the wild's backstory to present
an alternative to that which we see in
age of calamity so let's start with why
this would have been
impossible in breath of the wild
as epic as the master sword mission in
age of calamity was
it unfortunately left us with two
different versions of events which are
incompatible with one another
on one side we have breath of the wild
plus creating a champion
and on the other we have age of calamity
so what are the biggest differences when
it comes to how link got the sword in
these two different timelines
well to start off creating a champion
established that link got the legendary
blade
years before the events of the calamity
and the book makes this clear
on multiple occasions first off we have
the part which has been referenced
numerous times by other theorists which
is this section on page 376
where it states that he was in
possession of the sword for a number of
years prior to becoming a champion and
he was likely around
12 or 13 years old when it happened and
second the event of link extracting the
master sword is listed as something that
occurred
even before the sheikah slate was even
discovered and as we all know at the
beginning of age of calamity
impa is already in possession of the
slate days before link travels to korok
forest to pull the master sword
link is also already 17 years old in
this story when he acquires the sword
whereas in the book he was supposedly 12
or 13. now you might say well
age of calamity involves time travel
right so the timing of events simply
changed because of that
well no that would be impossible the
game makes it clear that age of
calamity's reality did not exist until
terrico jumped into the past
so assuming that age of calamity is a
traditional timeline split like the one
from ocarina of time
anything that happened before terraco
arrived in the past would have to be a
carbon copy of breath the wild storyline
since it quite literally splits off of
that timeline and it is only then that
things start changing because of his
influence
tereko arrives only a few weeks before
the calamity is set to occur
the champions have not been approached
yet but the sheikah slate has already
been discovered making it impossible for
his presence to have had
any effect on how and when link got the
sword he should have already been in
possession of the sword when the
guardian arrives but as we all know
that's not the case
so right away this leaves us with two
completely different chronologies
and under normal circumstances we would
simply have to make the consideration of
which piece of media holds more weight
in terms of canonicity
a third-party book or a third-party game
i've spoken to other theorists about
this at the time
and we agreed that a game would probably
have priority over a book if it was just
creating a champion versus age of
calamity in this case
however in my opinion there is one thing
that trumps both sources
altogether and that is breath of the
wild itself
hence in this particular case breath of
the wild would have to be the
determining factor
so which version of events does breath
of the wild side with
well at first it doesn't seem like the
game has much to say about how link got
the master sword
in every memory from 100 years ago he
already has it but it never makes it
clear when
and how that is until you get the second
dlc pack the champion's ballad here the
game sheds a bit more light on some of
the events which took place prior to the
calamity we see how zelda first
approached the pilots the ceremony where
they were officially appointed as
champions
some of the time they spent together as
a group etc but more importantly for
this topic is that we gain
access to the diaries of the four
champions personal memoirs in which they
describe their thoughts and experiences
both during and prior to the calamity
and on two occasions these stories
confirmed that not only did link
already have the master sword he was
also already selected as the chosen
knight who would slay ganon
long before the royal family even
started selecting candidates to pilot
the divine beasts
ravali describes his joy and pride when
zelda came to ask him to pilot vametto
only to quickly shift his tone as soon
as he found out that his role was
nothing more than that of a support for
some chosen knight he's never met before
and that he is not the one
tasked with taking gannon down himself
in turn mifa states that link came to
visit her at zora's domain right after
divine beast farouta was discovered but
before
zelda came to ask her to pilot the beast
and she specifically says that during
this visit
link already had the sword and mind you
even more time passes after that as it
took a while for her father king dorafan
to finally agree to mifa becoming the
champion of varuta
as at first he was hesitant for a while
link allegedly even fought a lino atop
pleime's mountain with the master sword
before her father gave his blessing
according to mifa's written word so by
the looks of it breath of the wild
points to creating a champion's version
of events being the true story
link already had the sword long before
the pilots were selected
age of calamity says no to that and here
link pulls the sword after the champions
obliged to pilot the beast
and in their presence no less and i
think we all know why this part of age
of calamity story is different they
simply didn't want link to start off
with the master sword
right at the beginning of the game and
from a gameplay perspective i get that
not only would it make a lot of the
early weapons useless i mean why would i
use a broadsword if i have the most
iconic and one of the more powerful
weapons in the game
and i'm pretty sure they also wanted to
have an epic master sword pull in this
story
it's kind of zelda tradition at this
point the first hyrule warriors had it
too
but the unfortunate side effect of this
change is that this part of the lord
does mess with that which breath of the
wild and the book has set up
all this could have been fixed by either
having terrico arrive
earlier in the timeline before link got
the master sword and then introducing a
time jump have link pull the master
sword in a flashback either through
gameplay or a cutscene or both or make
it more clear that age of calamity's
timeline is not a traditional timeline
split but instead a different reality
that has always
existed alongside breath of the wild one
with its own sequence of events with
or without the presence of terrico but
since this is not the case
i have to give the edge to breath of the
wild and creating a champion
again a first party game with
complementary book versus a third party
spin-off is an easy choice i would say
unless nintendo themselves step forward
and say hey you know how he said that
link got the master sword this way
well forget about that retcon this is
what actually happened 100 years ago
but until that happens i'm gonna have to
go with team breath of the wild slash
creating a champion
with that said that means we are now
back to not knowing much about the
circumstances surrounding link's first
encounter with the master sword
all we have is hearsay from two
champions and a couple of paragraphs
from a book both of which
only give a suggestion when he
approximately could have gotten the
sword but not how
it happened so now i want to present my
alternative
a way how link could have found his way
to the sword based on what we know from
breath of the wild and creating a
champion while
ignoring age of calamity's version of
events and treating that as its own
separate story one which only applies to
age of calamities timeline and not
breath of the wild
so here we go
[Music]
although link's family is mostly veiled
in mystery we do know that his father
was an accomplished knight who served
the royal family we don't know if he
died during the calamity or before but
for this story this doesn't really
matter
all that matters is that link likely
became a knight like his father before
him for the same reason that a
blacksmith's son would also become a
blacksmith when they grow up
we learned from mifa's diary that link
was exceptionally skilled in combat from
a very early age
being able to even best adults when he
was only around
4 years old a bit hard to believe but i
guess he is the chosen hero after all
i mean the hero of time defeated
monsters 10 times his size when he was
only 9 years old so
you know anyway if we were to go off of
what creating a champion tells us link
would have been around 12 to 13 years
old when he first pulled the master
sword which
is quite young but since link was
already quite powerful
even from a very young age this does
make sense the only reason why he wasn't
able to pull the sword in breath of the
wild initially is because of the stasis
he was put under for 100 years which
understandably took a massive toll on
him although it's never stated where
link found it i do think the master
sword was in the pedestal at korok
forest when he did
creating a champion states that the
master sword has averted many calamities
alongside past heroes
and that it's placed inside the pedestal
to recover from the damage it incurs
from those battles
as such since the last calamity was
successfully halted 10 000 years ago
it's only natural that back then they
followed the tradition of returning the
sword where it belongs
each time it fulfilled its role this
happens many times in other installments
as well where either the hero himself or
someone else returns the sword at the
end of the game
except in the wind waker i just got
stabbed in the face
now let's quickly talk about link's
origins where did he
initially come from despite no
definitive proof i'm quite sure that
link did indeed originate from hiteno
village
there are simply more hints that this
was the place where he was raised than
any other place in hyrule like the house
which was conveniently abandoned for 100
years and link coincidentally being
absent for 100 years
small hints from nintendo employees it
all points towards hatteno being link's
original hometown
and i love it because link's from hoteno
village
so it's very cute glimpse into his life
again nothing is proven indefinitely but
i'm just going with the most likely
option
this of course doesn't mean that link
spent his entire life in a tenno in fact
as soon as he was drafted as a knight
himself it makes sense that he would
have been living in and around hyrule
castle town for the later parts of his
life
knights often live in quarters or
barracks after all so that they are
always ready to defend the castle
this may have been the case for his
father as well zelda specifically
mentions link's father during one of the
memories the fact that the royal
princess
knew who link's father was means that he
probably had made a name for himself and
likely had a high rank in hyrule's army
perhaps a captain or even a general with
that said
what would steer a young kid of 12 to 13
years old in the direction of hyrule's
great forest
alone as we know the resting place of
the master sword is considered dangerous
by the hylians a place where one can
easily get lost and wander around for
days and get nowhere
even during the calamity monsters and
guardians did not make it into korok
forest it remains secluded
a safe place for the spirits of the
forest overseen by their guardian deity
the great deku tree
the only person we've seen visiting the
forest besides link is princess zelda
when she returns the master sword after
link fell in battle
it's unclear how she knows her way
around the forest but it's safe to say
that this wasn't her first visit
as the deku tree seems to be well
acquainted with her still the forest
largely remains left alone by mortals
so how did link find his way here and at
such a young age
whether he was living in hattano or
castletown at the time it's still a long
ways away for a boy his
age to be traveling here alone right
well there is one location which could
explain
everything one hylian structure close to
hyrule's great forest which could have
played a big role in this
since link was extremely talented with a
sword from a very young age
it probably didn't take long for his
father to draft him into hyrule's army
by the time link would join the army the
prophecy of ganon's return had already
come to light years prior
zelda was only 7 at the time and there's
only 1 year age gap between her and link
the hylian army likely needed every bit
of manpower they could get in
preparation for ganon's return so it's
only natural that an exceptionally
talented swordsman like link would be
more than welcome despite his young
age and where does anyone go before they
join the actual army
exactly boot camp in this case hyrule's
military training camp close to the
border of hyrule's great forest
as is the case with many military
training camps the cadets often sleep in
barracks in and around the same area
so link likely spent at least a couple
of months at the training camp together
with the other recruits and it is during
this time that i believe link found his
way to the master sword
as is often the case with the master
sword the hero doesn't choose
it but rather the sword chooses the hero
and since ganon's return was only a few
years away
the sword was likely ready to be found
by the next hero worthy of wielding it
while present at the training camp
link may have felt a pull towards the
great forest
an unknown force calling out to him
until one night the young swordsman
finally gave into the temptation
sneaking away from the barracks to
venture into the misty forest alone
driven by intuition or perhaps guided by
some divine influence
he managed to make his way through the
forest successfully without getting lost
once he arrives at the foot of the great
deku tree he lay his eyes upon the
sparkling blade
and with that link pulls the master
sword perhaps without realizing that he
has been chosen for a great but
dangerous task which will determine the
future of hyrule
word quickly spread about the young man
who emerged carrying the legendary sword
that seals the darkness
and it wouldn't be long until he was
recognized as the one who would have to
face ganon alongside the princess faced
with a tremendous responsibility this is
also the time when links started to grow
more and more silent
going from a bold outspoken kid to a
silent and burdened young adult
and that is how i envisioned it
happening but that's just my take
on it perhaps you have a completely
different scenario in mind
i know i've been kinda harsh on age of
calamity in this video
but please bear in mind that i don't
dislike the game in any way
in the end it doesn't even really matter
as arlo stated in his review
of the game breath of the wild and age
of calamity are vastly different games
each with their own rules and mechanics
in one link struggles with a single
lynel even in the late game
and in the other he mows down enemies by
the thousands but that's the nature of a
warriors game
age of calamity was epic and although i
don't consider it as
canon as breath of the wild i still
think the master sword pull in that game
was very cool and unique
it happens under extreme pressure and
during a boss fight nonetheless
does it fit with breath the world's
narrative in my opinion
no but at the end of the day
entertainment is more important than
lore consistency
it would have been cool if we got both
but that's the curse of a spin-off game
i guess
thank you for watching let me know what
you think how do
you envision link got the master sword
in breath of the wild do you still fully
accept age of calamity as canon be sure
to leave a comment down below
a special shout out as always goes to my
amazing patreons and members who
continue to make this content possible
and please welcome emo kid and brett
rosenbaum as my latest supporters as
well as an additional shout out to star
demon who just upgraded their pledge
as always you guys are the best and that
is all for now keep an eye out for the
one year anniversary video next week
i hope to see you then this is dawn
signing off and have a good one
[Music]
you